hey all right that's 50 guys it was a
play isn't it so long okay so this my
play right and it's being tracked by
radar station which is on the ground
okay so put that guy right now then
plays altitudes given to you that's
perpendicular to the ground so if I have
the ground over here there's a
perpendicular distance don't get 10,000
meters okay at what rate is the radar
rotating okay what's going on here the
plane I probably could have made this
question even right here actually I'm
just trying to be concise vo6 you don't
- right - that's where the planes
traveling towards the radar station for
some extreme okay so it's going at the
rates of compliance of us okay and
therefore the radar is having to turn to
keep up with the plane okay eventually
the plane apart right over here okay
so I've got this kind of position sorry
this kind of what I'm happening because
the radars looking at the plane and the
radars rotating at least at the moment
say if I put the plane in a new position
if I put the plane say here okay you can
see it's rotated upwards right so it's
an angle of elevation for me okay okay
so that angle of elevation that would
that's the rotation and that's what's
changing so this angle here is the
particular quantity that I'm interested
all right okay now we said that this
thing is moving towards the radar
station okay so that means even though
the altitude might stay the same one of
the distances on here is changing which
one where would you put it
yeah okay so again I'm supplying that
information to you like I say I can make
the question a moment ago so that's
arrow completely out of the years which
is why sometimes these rates of change
but questions very long okay but I mean
it could and then it'd just be what's
the quantity that's changing
we're gonna have this angle changing
right but what directly this plane is
moving yes
so there's a link that's changing namely
this one okay so I guess you'd call that
now I said to you before sometimes we
have issues with units right I already
have two units on my diagram okay so
I've got kilometers and I've got meters
what it is we think so this would become
10 kilometers right all of us let's go
with that okay in my work I went to
meters so I made that and then I changed
it to a second let's just go with it
because so therefore passing form is as
informal as I guess all of this
employment is also okay now I guess
that's going to be three kilometers over
there so that's the particular point in
time so how's the angle changing all
right I was transferred service
transpersonal more mathematical language
or what the question is giving us I've
got power at the moment take 900
climbers bra that way okay so how would
i express that mathematically what
quantity is changing
it's X right so I'm being told it's not
a little bit for our it's actually DX on
the team it's its distance over time
okay this is what I know what quantity
am i after yeah good this thing is
changing the angle is changing so what I
want what's unknown is defeat upon DT
okay sir
chain rule right I'm gonna need a defeat
up on something and something upon DT
well for X's right very well but you see
why I'm always putting this thing in
place first because it answered the
question on well what's the important
information in the question okay so DX
DX okay so I have this part that's gonna
be constant I need some relationship
between X and theta X beside this yeah
I'm gonna have to introduce some trig
ratios right okay so I do not know this
length I probably could work it out but
it's also changing right probably a
better option is to connect the quantity
I'm interested in this angle and the
other side that I actually know which is
10 okay so if I say 10 feet up and
that's opposite on adjacent right so 10
over X yes okay now what was that again
do you theater on DX or DX on D theta
whichever one I can get it would be fine
which II think could be easiest to get
out of this equation
defeater RDX should i differentiate with
respect to X or should I differentiate
with respect to theta which one ha that
was interesting I think I heard equal
parts okay let me see right um if I want
to differentiate with respect to X I
need to make feet are the subject right
so I would say theta is tan inverse of
10 over X and then you differentiate if
I want to differentiate with respect to
theta I need to make X the subject right
so that would look like I guess these
are swap places right so X would be 10
affion
yes so which do you prefer I think I
prefer regulatory rather than inverse
trig I don't like I mean that's not nice
either but I think it's better to deal
with fractions and square roots and okay
so this is what I need to differentiate
now just in case you can't remember this
is this is 10 cos theta on sine theta
the reason why I'm drawing that is
because maybe you don't remember the
result for the derivative of cos theta
with your head okay so what's the
derivative of this what would you use
you okay so therefore my derivative
sorry on this will be 10 times the
tensor stuff right right
okay question rules what comes first V
sorry Athena you - which is negative
sine theta that way that was on vu -
minus UV - okay so because V na and V -
is cos theta again yes all over V
squared happy so far
so I've got a negative sign spectating
yeah and negative cos squared theta T up
Quito anyway that's going sine squared
cos squared sine squared plus squared is
1 but I've got a negative on both of
them right so this is going to be all of
this numerator would just be minus 1
minus 10 and then I suppose I could
write it as on sine squared theta but I
can also write it as which reciprocals
that right why is it minus another part
of the ten o'clock yeah okay so there's
my derivative okay so now I can come
over here and say D theta I confuse
myself sorry that should be a theá--
let's try again
DX on D theta is minus ten Kosek
all right no I've got the excellently
feet up I really want to do theater on
the X right
so therefore yeah I'm gonna take the
reciprocal of this reciprocal of the
reciprocal so what's it gonna be I guess
it'd be signs ready okay yes okay times
what's the activity it's not
okay hmm
one of things I mentioned before is that
because these questions are talking
about physical things right one of the
things you should always do wherever
it's appropriate where we can really
when you get the end of section of
working is you should look at your
result and you should think does this
make sense
does it make sense what does this mean
that defeat on DT is minus 90 can you
tell me is this a go getting bigger or
smaller
what's it meant to be doing it's meant
to be getting bigger because it's going
up I'm look I'm watching the plane and
it's going increasing it overhead right
so this is what to be positive what's
gone wrong
ah yes it's not 900 the exit is he is
not that hungry right again this I
caught you again see this thing is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
okay so actually dx/dt is - okay make
sense hey by the way though the reason
I'm trying to draw you through this is
so that you can do this yourself and you
can realize me wait something has gone
wrong why is it the way that is so 99
scrip Tina okay now what did the
question say it said tell me this right
d theta/dt when when the plane is 3,000
meters laterally away what is laterally
so as opposed to vertically right so
it's a bit like where we're looking top
down okay so I'm I'm after this value X
I want that's a big 3,000
so this poses a problem what's the
problem
yeah this function we've got for defeat
on a team which is what we want right
that's the quantity is not in terms of
the variable I'm after
okay so what do we do right so I am
gonna have to find out what the theta
should be so if this is 3 and this is 10
I actually already know what Peter
should be from this equation right
because that's the relationship between
theorems
okay so let's see where should I put
this I guess I'm saying when X is equal
to 3 what's theta now this is true this
is a true statement and you can um go
into your calculator and work out what
10 inverse 10 on 3 is I think we can do
one better I think we can do one better
because this is this is not going to be
exact right I know a bit of a I didn't I
didn't say you know give me an
approximation so it should be exact
how could we get an exact value out of
this the clue is already much more clear
is that on this function is not just in
terms of theta its in terms of a trig
function of theta right namely sign I
can't work out what sine Peter is Connor
and I can work out exactly because it's
in a right angle is it not okay if this
is 3 and this is 10 what should this big
let's say it's square root of 100 plus 9
yes this here at this particular point
in time will be the square root of one
hundred and nine kilometers
yes
so therefore sine theta will be opposite
on what news so better than this right I
should say sine theta is equal to so
therefore at this particular point in
time defeat on the T is 90 times the
square of that so that's that okay
now this cell mistake is 109 looks prime
to me right yeah so we're sort of that's
it okay so there's DP DT now
qualen is nu we need to translate a bit
a little bit cuz this is a derivatives
got any units on it okay so what units
are being referred to here this is in
kilometers per hour hold on a second
kilometers per hour
uh I hope on a second hmm this is I
agree it's per hour there has to be an
angle measurement right but we know two
different ways to measure angles right
and neither of them were in this
question so how do you decide because
this number I take it if you choose
degrees or radians that's a bit there's
very different answers right so how do
you pick degrees or radians
let's see what's your instant walk ahead
if you're if your instinct is radians
okay
about about half the class am I so are
the rest of your degrees yes who's not
sure who's not sure I just have no idea
yeah I'll admit it's a it's a confusing
question okay so let's think about this
what would it mean one way or another
okay if this were degrees
okay let's think about what this
actually means what is 9000 on 109
what's what's it an actual what's it
what's it close to eighty two point yeah
so 83 mmm second what would that mean 83
degrees I moved 83 degrees in an hour
does that sound about right hmm
how far would I have to go how far my
head turning in 83 degrees it's going up
all this all the way it's almost going
overhead yes takes one hour to do that
does that make sense why doesn't it make
sense how can you know it doesn't make
sense that it would go that far right
and there should be three kilometers to
go right three pointers to go so what
happened the previous hour that means
what would this angle of being if it
took an hour to go 83 degrees the angle
will be down here somewhere right
think about what that what that looks
like does that make sense because I
actually have actually no I haven't got
so 10 but you're sort of going down
through the ground the plane would be
underground okay
83 is way too far okay so hold on if I
can get to read
I'm gonna take the right airtime won't
you have the oh wow its radiance if I
had it's just a satisfaction okay but it
still doesn't answer the question of why
if I if I have no angle unit introduced
okay the rest of the units are
introduced why should I be fault two
radians okay yeah so I'm doing all this
different units right why I can have any
differentiate in radians why should it
matter which units I use but I can
differentiate in kilometers or meters or
whatever that should make a difference
why radians it comes to angles cuz
that's right
you could any differentiate radio hmm
you think about this for a minute okay
this goes back to what we learned last
year you may remember it because when
you're integrating trig functions and I
say you know okay
you kind of know must be radians cuz
it's a pie in there right but you know
really I mean I couldn't even plants
food degrees just be very small okay
except I taught you that you can only it
only makes sense for radians okay so
there might be why you remember you know
still doesn't answer the question so
when you have to think about it okay so
let's take a step back what kinds of
things you have to watch out for in this
question because you're going to get a
few related rates of change questions
with angles in there number one you're
gonna have to get some relationship
between the distances that they give you
okay because almost always the rates
that are supplied are distance rates
okay and then you have to relate them to
an angle so use treatment okay use the
right tree ratio secondly when you're
differentiating watch out because think
I've eat up what's that equal to again
when you differentiate it so just be
careful that you don't lose track of
yourself when you do all this side
working thirdly what before watch out
for the sign of your rates have changed
me
if they're decreasing they're negative
and mostly watch these units